für einige sushi liebhaber hat der
mindestlohn jetzt schon konkrete folgen
die röhrchen werden zum jahresanfang
teurer weil jetzt hier jeder mindestens
8 euro 50 verdienen muss erhöht der chef
die preise es wird sich einpendeln ich
denke mal als wir ihn ja so von zirka
einer gewöhnungsphase von ein bis zwei
monaten
das ist auch zeitlich sehr gut der
januar ist immer so ein ganz ruhiger
umsatz schwacher monat sagen wir's mal
so februar - drei tage
das heißt bis märz alles vergessen und
dann geht's weiter
für die mitarbeiter im sushi laden aber
ändert sich vieles
die liefer fahrer zum beispiel jobbten
hier bisher nur tageweise für sechs euro
50 pro stunde keiner verdiente mehr als
450 euro insgesamt nur davon allein kann
man in deutschland nicht leben
pfarrer hubert piskol ihn nutzt den
minijob um seine unterstützung vom amt
aufzubessern
erst ungelernt und arbeitslos jeder euro
zählt man hat er natürlich auch ein
bisschen trinkgeld und das lohnt sich da
noch ein bisschen mehr
nun will sein chef die vielen mini jobs
in einige vollzeitstellen umwandeln
manche verlieren dadurch ihren
nebenverdienst für den arbeitslosen aber
ist es eine chance auf einen richtigen
job
man hat hoffnung auf die festeinstellung
aber wie gesagt da muss man nochmal sich
hinsetzen und darüber reden ob alles
passt und so neue vollzeitstellen das
ende der dumpinglöhne
das soll der mindestlohn bewirken doch
das neue gesetz hat sich noch nicht
überall herumgesprochen
eigentlich schon java gemeinschaft
bezahlt mich aber halt nur sechs euro
viele fragen auch wenn der taxibranche
bisher bekamen die fahrer prozent vom
umsatz ihr stundenlohn lag mal über und
oft unter dem mindestlohn und nun noch
nicht sicher ob sie erzählen mit uns für
uns gut ist oder nicht wir müssen ein
bisschen abwarten jetzt durchsetzt also
wir wissen noch nicht ehrlich gesagt wie
es denn bei uns läuft die taxipreise
werden steigen fürchten beobachter die
branche sieht viele zehntausend jobs in
gefahr
im gegenteil sagen die gewerkschaften
der mindestlohn werde mehr nachfrage und
jobs schaffen
vorausgesetzt die unternehmen haben
keine gelegenheit zu tricksen
das verhindert wird dass über die
arbeitszeiten manipuliert wird dass die
leute unbezahlte mehrarbeit leisten
müssen
das muss ausgeschlossen werden wir
müssen uns darum kümmern was mit
bereitschaftsdiensten passiert was mit
wege zeiten passiert mit standzeiten
passiert das muss geregelt werden es
muss verhindert werden dass abhängige
beschäftigung in scheinselbstständigkeit
überführt wird auch da brauchen wir
entsprechende kontrollen und insofern
ist ein effizientes kontrollsystem der
schlüssel für die funktion des
mindestlohns in der kulturszene
allerdings gilt all dies nicht künstler
werden selten fest angestellt und meist
für einzelne projekte engagiert für
solche aufträge an selbstständige
künstler gibt es keinen mindestlohn
spontan würde ich sagen da träumen wir
von vom mindestlohn weil wenn man
natürlich alles zusammenzählt also alle
probenzeiten was man sich drauf drücken
muss ein partien oder was man auch üben
muss dann ist das halt ich lache auch
die meisten praktikanten in deutschland
haben jetzt anspruch auf 8 euro 50 pro
stunde
das kann sich das kleine theater nicht
leisten
praktikanten die jetzt nicht in ihrer
ausbildung sind sondern eine ausbildung
schon hinter sich gebracht haben können
wir nicht beschäftigen
das ist zu viel geld und das schlimme
die schlimme situation in berlin ist ja
die dass man für nur ein wenig mehr geld
dann eben einen vollprofi auch schon
bekommt manche verlieren ihren job
andere verdienen mehr und unternehmen
nutzen das neue gesetz um die preise zu
erhöhen
schon vom ersten tag an hat der
mindestlohn den deutschen arbeitsmarkt
verändert